you've enjoyed him on TV and movies for
years as a matter of fact he played
himself and justified he was really
great doing that and he's known around
these parts as the man who looks at me
and calls me daddy because that is who I
am when it comes to fantasy football
how'd you like that intro Michael around
well you should have said should we do
it again enough live TV but I'm going to
do it again we can get a mulligan you
need to put it put in their senior
fantasy football analyst senior fantasy
folk a can we can we can we do that
again can you can you play the music
coming back here okay
because I wonder when you when you talk
about a lob tron I'm talking your
fantasy football analytic I'm trying to
I'm trying to do it
welcome back to Rich Eisen che he is a
senior fantasy football analyst a Mike
is Michael Rapaport guys Rock fell to
fogive any of my current and yes a big
announcement big announcement you are
I'm joining the DirecTV family yes you
are every Sunday fantasy zone mm-hmm
with the Guru with Kay Adams okay
sometimes in this studio will no longer
be the Rich Eisen studio we're getting
rid all the power failure that will pop
again that yes every propaganda every
Sunday as soon as the games tip-off soon
as they kick off I'll be there all
fantasy everything you are joining the
cast of fantasy zone every Sunday every
Sunday I'm so hyped about fantasy
football I'm so hyped about being in
here every single so sometimes I'll be
in York sometimes I'll be here again the
studio will be my death whatever the
hell that is that I'll I don't walk
we're going to get this place cleaned up
spruce it up all this stuff these lis
all this propaganda the rich eyes and
coasters are staying sir you're going to
stay but they're gonna stay outside the
studio and then you can get your guys to
move it back in but every Sunday channel
704 right here on DirecTV I'm joining
the fantasy zone some games you'll see
me my highs hmm some games you'll see my
low no okay so these are my questions
for I have for you okay you're joining
Kay Adams John Hanson Jason Smith y'all
channel 704 right here on director now
wait okay
now two things one um have you been
given the green light to drop the f
bombs and stuff like that that you know
I'm agreeing on this show I know you did
we needn't come close no one even go get
any cycle I'm not saying I'm able to
work yes yes
I'm Adam have you been given the green
light to work blue well I have been
given the green light to work but we're
going to do with hand signals and so I
feel like something bad is happening
it's going to be like I'm gonna do like
this like or you'll be able to read it
like so they'll just have their finger
on like on the button but you know like
it's going to be like this like I'm
gonna be like well cuz kg has his curse
button right yeah an area 21 on int you
don't need a button I need like a
three-second panic button I might not be
able to keep up with myself anymore than
I suck at work blue it's going to be all
fantasy everything I'm giving expert
advice because I am a senior fantasy
mouth analyst mine I gave a dissertation
to get that title what do you mean where
where'd you give it it's a secret
location sort of a bunch of panic Jenny
and whatever secretly Mennonite two and
a half hours hope done everything into
the last two fantasy football seasons
and I'm ready to go just last year was
the Rookie of the Year in fantasy this
year I'm going for MVP and there ain't
no suspension there's no days off
there's no rest days for me well because
you're also going to appear on this show
every Friday to have a conversation of
fantasy football's you'll have a regular
presence here yes I'm pleased about with
this caveat okay I have to ask a caveat
is the cabbie I'll give me the fancy
words because here we go well should I
put on my glasses today if you try to
intimidate me see here's for the caveat
I just put on my glasses for dropping
the Big C word to you okay um hehe well
I just you know make sure you don't
think it's spelled with a k so here's
the thing I just took my glasses off to
make Caruso they may Rousseau's their
props I counter politically just
Powerman oh here you are now if you are
a senior fantasy beautiful excuse sir
okay yes sir
you can't just say oh well I'm an actor
I'm a comedian I'm an actor I'm a
podcaster so I'm just talking fantasy
football because I'm a fan people are
getting information from you that's
correct might be making moves because
they view you as an expert is a pundit
you have to come correct this year as
they should they should come to me
because let me tell you some rich yeah
I'm not following nobody else's trends
I'm setting the trends
watch the rankings people watch the
rankings watch where you go for
information okay there's a lot of people
out there they're selling you a bag of
uh what rankings we know the rankings
out there I'm not naming names I'm not
putting anybody on blast in the plane
Network somebody but listen trust your
gut there's no friends in fantasy
there's no feelings in fantasy those
into mentality and fantasy so why should
your gut be trusted because I'm not
playing games cuz cuz you're gonna cuz
my gosh should be trusted rich yes I'm
gonna believe for this fantasy you you
know what it was like to take me on last
year you defeated me that's what you
have here I'm losing thought your user
ID also a loser essentially that's fine
but there's but then you don't you win
some you lose some
yes but do we have a nice little we had
Louis right right that's great look you
are you are awesome at what at what no
no you're awesome at the attitude yeah
you're awesome at the give and take
that's fun doing that up it's going it's
flirtation it's fun texting you curse
words out of nowhere
yes great because your reactions are
great you're clean on the air this guy's
go filthy mouth you'll see you know I'm
talking about like potty Molly made me
blush a few times it I don't think test
its disgusting text yes
did your family know what you speak or
just holding on the wine of sports you
have to Walter why this works like in
front everybody to this and then you're
like I'm the guy who does the not yet I
work blue I don't cook blue is what
you're saying that's the difference Oh
boom that's next level okay so who is
number one overall
I'm not Tomo who's number one doc David
Robert and Le'Veon Bell we you know what
the thing is too right now is who not to
take that's the most people we all know
who the top 10 top 20 guys are we've
studied it we like some more than the
other number one David Johnson levy
although you're going to win with either
one of them but you're not concerned
that Le'Veon Bell hasn't strolled into
camp you I think that he's the kind of
freak athlete hmm I go with David
Johnson but I think he's going to stroll
into camp and I'm not worried about it
not being ready not being in shape the
injury's concern me but then I mean that
can happen with anybody but the thing
for me now in all series
this is cool to stay away from like last
year I love Amari Cooper I love him but
I think he's almost too good to big for
his own good he gets so much attention
in the second half of this season last
year his a they threw the ball to him so
much less Seattle Seahawks every single
year running backs they haven't been the
same since that in hand the ball off to
Marshawn Lynch in the Super Bowl they
don't know what they're doing at the
goal line they don't know who they're
giving the ball to so my thing right now
is focus on who you're not going to know
your guys stick with you guys and be
ready because you're going to be plopped
down in different Dressman we're playing
in the Jerry Cantrell al Jennings
charity league he's coming in now is for
you to talk about I don't know where I'm
going in that draft but I know who my
guys are you could give me the first
pick twelve pick the 19 pick I'm ready
I'm coming for you I'm going to drag you
this year
well let me just put it this way um good
luck with that huh um that'll noted that
is not happening thank you but I don't
need appreciate well I know if somebody
was wearing a jumpsuit cleaning up here
inappropriately how do you please I know
I mean we need you to put on the
jumpsuit again actually clean it up but
I mean where would you for instance all
right let's take a break come back in 60
seconds yeah because I'm gonna throw
some players at you and you are a
fantasy expert I want the fantasy advice
senior analyst please okay fantasy
football so we're talking in your ear to
play this information write it down
seeing your fantasy seeing an analyst
senior senior where does the senior delt
what is it we're in I think it's an age
thing fantasy football senior analyst or
you already man like he's top of the
chassis you never gave a dissertation in
front of these people I want to hit you
with names and you need to come like a
pundit okay come like a pundit no
problem because people are gonna my god
I'll wear your glasses when I do it
uh-oh well don't stretch him out
you know you gotta really before dating
a girl fogged up me they are the kind of
wipes for me because I'm using as a prop
Michael Rapaport back in 60 seconds here
Jerry can't show Mike Inez is well
Tamron wake of the Dolphins also still a
coming your calls
[Music]
did you see Michael Rapaport that Dana
white with Paulie Malignaggi saying I
got shoved down I didn't get knocked
down he puts out the video of McGregor
flat-out knocking him to the campus
knocking him to the cameras did you see
them I saw it I've never seen any
sparring footage in all my years of
being a boxing fan ever never I've never
seen it have you no well that's a classy
move this has become well I mean it's
the fight before the fight listen are
you Irish I'm far from that night
another who do you got to win a fight I
think I'm still gonna go mayweather feel
gonna go mayweather what do you think is
gonna happen I don't know I think
McGregor you don't attack the first two
three rounds how many times have you
said nothing's possible and something's
possible and it happens in sports what
you say Rudy my man this is not uh but
neither world wars but but you know
Tyson lost nobody thought Buster doesn't
they don't know you're I am these are
you eating sushi getting foot rubs from
four or five six girls all ranked nobody
thought Brady could go on his run nobody
thought Kurt Warner just got put in the
Pro Football Hall of Fame let's keep
going on and on with it that you can't
never going to happen
anything could happen he's a competitor
right but I just don't think he has a
chance to win the boxing match with this
style of fighter and I think that the
circus
will be going back to Ireland August 26
with blackened eyes yeah and you know
some couple of bucks in his pocket it's
quite a bit so so you think it was cheap
of Dana White - yeah put that video I
think that that that press tour was vile
on everybody's part
and and I'm not even a may wear the pen
I've never rooted for him a fight in a
fight just because of his style and
cause of his antics but in this case I'm
rooting for boxing to win and and the
sport of boxing to win and and I just
think that I think it's going to be is
my prediction and ulcers I think the
first two or three rounds are going to
be chaotic like McGregor is gonna try to
come at him and it's going to be wild
and Floyd Ulm you know make him miss a
lot and he might hit him on the side of
the head like McDonough did and we all
[ __ ] McDonough is beating the crap out
of Floyd and when you watch the replay
what he barely even hit him in the
second time he kills him and they
the rest of our fight I think is going
to be pretty easy and I think McGregor
is going to get peppered I don't think
he's going to put him under any physical
duress that he hasn't been in in MMA
because McGregor is tough but I just
think at the end of the day I think it's
going to be a real letdown but I do
think the first two or three rounds are
going to be will be worth the 99 bucks
that I'm not spending hmm can I come to
your house and watch the fight because I
refuse to spend a nickel I don't know I
was thinking of going to it actually I'm
thinking of going to Las Vegas Nevada
for okay and your hookup for ticket to
that but you couldn't get four floor
seats for the big three yesterday
hangout Excuse watch me do my job as a
Cylon Michael Rapaport I my honor to get
you two good seats
anyway I sit in an only six they would
not that was in the nosebleeds but in
speaking of the big three though uh
yesterday yes okay because I was there
yes how do i how do I look as a silent
right you look confident you stocked
around the court yes you did you think
um you know we it was great to see
Charles Oakley by the way yesterday I
haven't mentioned this guy's Charles
Oakley played for the first time noises
yeah coach right throughout this entire
season he threw he threw an elbow at Al
Harrington and it was the greatest thing
I've seen in in a long time that was a
ton of fun to actually see Oakley do his
thing and Snoop was out there performing
that was a lot of fun wasn't chaos right
competitive games right why didn't i
verson play does he not play he's
injured he he I think he's done I think
he's done playing I think you know he
played earlier I know he had gotten hurt
yes you know Allen Iverson's not going
to listen he didn't complain during his
years just as an NBA player played with
brokenness dislocated that he ain't
going to tell well the reason why I'm
not playing he just is not in his makeup
to make excuses but you know he got the
you know talked to doctor doc says not
in your best interest to be playing
right so what is it around these guys
they seem to be really do seem into it
like it's not an act although they love
it the competition is tough it's
passionate and they're having fun and
it's been an honestly it's been an honor
for me like an I've had outer body
experiences like interviewing dr. Jay
it's great to see him on a basketball
court or George Gervin or Rick Mahorn or
oak and Gary Payne it's been
and an honor are they getting more
players do you think more MORE next year
I think well wonder was there yesterday
I think some be exciting Lamar Odom is
going to play next year um they're
talking about Kobe they're talking about
chemical net now that there are a lot
reality now you're talking now you're
talking and also you know if I may you
know there is like what 15 minutes in
between games 14 minutes in between you
know maybe a little more water normal
was la how it was star star filled arena
lot going on yeah you know we wanted to
put on a good show in becoming the games
so I think the game ship in between
should be shorter minutes just like
let's go let's go after another you
don't know I mean well how much tell me
we just took a six-minute commercial
break you're talking about you know when
36 minutes commercial breaks right so in
between games give the guy's a chance
then you know get warmed up get a little
lather
a little louder when you come up before
the show I see you're sweating you're
gloom you get oiled down that's exactly
I drop you're playing competitive guys
don't have to play tiddlywinks rich it
was it was just fun to see Oakley out
there in New Jersey and getting these
guys and seeing dr. J and dr. J and
Clyde Drexler were where the coaches
against each other yesterday just fun to
see that Michael Rapaport here on the
Rich Eisen show again you're joining the
cast of fantasy zone this season you're
also going to be here on Friday talking
about all things sports yes I think
you're in the or does it show there'll
be a lot of fun doing that so let's put
your hat on for your your senior fantasy
football and looking at on I need
players that you're looking to get
I need players that you should be
Marshall I'm looking to get Brandon
Marshall okay he's going to have round
hit what round would you even get him in
well you're gonna give me it's a 12 to
it people are most likely in a 10 12
team league where would you go second
third round on Brandon okay no no good
yeah around or something like that
yeah I think fifth round and I think
that unlike last year everybody was like
wait to the quarterbacks way to the
quarterback this year
Tom Aaron Burr and Aaron Rodgers if
they're available early you got to go
for it
because for me in fantasy there is no
guarantees you know that yes but there
are guarantees with Tom Brady and Aaron
Rodgers and they're going to have big
ears what round you take these
quarterbacks whether you hand
what where you are in in your your draft
order and what's going on but if you're
late in the second round okay I wouldn't
be mad at you if you pick Tom Brady on
the smooth back I will wear Aaron
Rodgers oh you're not a winner I mean
what do you think I'm I'm sorry I'm
guarantee I am done choosing a
quarterback in the first two rounds of
my fantasy draft finished end of story
I got my ass handed to me sometimes by
Matt Ryan last year and somebody grabbed
him in the fourth or fifth round Philip
Rivers is going to have damn near 4,000
yards passing I agree
why why would you just go ahead and take
one of those guys for Kirk Cousins could
even Matthew Stafford is going to be
available I agree I agree I'll get them
there and the question is if you're
sitting there in round three you're in a
12-team League you're sitting there in
round three and you already have a
running back yeah and you already have a
wide receiver yes and you heard what I
just said about a quarterback I agree
and most everybody else has taken
running back off the board pretty much
everybody has got a starting running
back yes do you take Ezekiel Elliott in
the third round else draft the third
round if it only heard round it gave you
the circumstances in which you are
that's tough I would absolutely do that
six six K I know but you could get
through your fantasy football three and
three two and four and your six games if
you do that why do you want your
stressful you got at then you got when I
know but then you got Zeke in your back
pocket for those and you know the bye
weeks out of the way you'll be playing
in your playoffs I'm not I'm not saying
don't do it but I don't even look that
up God is more than four games in levian
you know and last you member Todd Gurley
his first year I'm not saying that Zeke
ugh it's not going to have a good year
but six six games is tough man and then
you take a look at what your fantasy
playoff schedule would be Brockman and
Michael Rapaport week 15 for the what
you say playoffs begin week 14 for most
weeks yes okay I'll give you 14 there at
the Giants yeah that's a problem week 15
at the Raiders week 16 home for the
Seattle Seahawks yeah you don't want any
part of the Zeke Elliott because you're
miss
the first segment in the first six and
then should you make the playoffs those
are three very difficult very difficult
he doesn't return to week eight either
right one seven they're off no cuz week
six they have a bye
so week seven there is his sixth is the
Cowboys sixth game of the year so he
won't return to week eight of your
fantasy football would you pick them in
the third round no I've now just told my
Sekhmet all I think he's a complete stay
away
I mean fourth round he ain't a stay away
but I just think you know it for if you
can get him in the fight it depends on
what's going on in the draft but but you
you it's it's going to be tough man it's
going to be tough with Ezekiel Elliott I
don't know what to do with this guy he
let me take some I've been mocks rafting
there's the rest mark drafting for the
password arrest not drafting the rest of
my drafting I did one on the way down
here I pulled over on the 110 freeway
safely had my hazards on I did a quick
18 snake draft
quick quick a team's plan you got to
have safety first yes listen at this
point everybody has been mock drafting
right okay but if you if you really want
to get focused you have to duress mock
pass but broke down last week well you I
don't know what you were doing in a
tanning booth growing facial hair yeah I
broke down
duress mock draft plan number one you
give back to your community you go to an
old-age home
volunteer to clean up the gymnasium okay
I love all the people my father's 84
while they're in there working out it
sounds like the slaughter of the lambs
and you're cleaning you're helping your
community you're helping your dress my
dress if you can mock draft while old
people are lifting five pound weights
going you're ready to win it that's my
mother we did we did a draft over here
on the 110 freeway I pulled right over X
at crisscross applesauce and I didn't I
got a minute mother's never lie your mom
what's your mom's name June 9 is sitting
on the couch ma ma is this true that he
really dressed my draft on the on the
shoulder of the 105 110 min are you
going to take a leak I'm going to do a
mock draft here man on the side of the
freeway crisscross applesauce
I got I guarantee you somebody got it on
snapchat if you got a picture of me on
the side of the free with my phone the
rest of my class like please send it to
retired by the way I don't want to be on
the 110 if people are snapped
adding pictures of you soft on the
shoulder the rest smartdraft by the way
I love that dress mock draft yeah
because my drafting is easy this is some
of the just a little portion of the Kean
analysis you will receive from the
senior fantasy football analyst Michael
Rapaport when he joins the cast of
fantasy so in this season on DirecTV
only channel 704 good to see you sir
good to see you too rich I just want to
ask you one final question you're you're
hooked up with the NFL yes so if I came
to you for some tickets like area where
am I going to be sitting you will be
sitting in great seats like the big
three gave me except they were just you
know a little bit of obstructed view
that's all okay but can I be your intern
so I get Raj I'll get your fee I'll be
like I'll be your guy on the field I'll
get you coffee huh give you some breath
mints when you're interviewing plays
make sure everything's fresh look Amy
tress take care of me
all right the CEO of the big three was
awesome and a great show yesterday I
would have had you right there with me
man okay I had you right there with me
well now I know Michael kind of me I
know for future big threes and then I'll
see you on Fridays oh yes right here on
the show Michael Rapaport is here eight
four four two oh four rich Cameron wake
and Jerry Cantrell on Mike Inez of
Allison chains and the dolphins also
showing up don't go in it thank you rich
all right so what would other duress
mock draft settings be Michael lowered
other freeway right um I told you that
old age home is a really really
underrated way and you're giving back to
the community so in there like a lunatic
in like it's called a win-win it's a
win-win yeah um the shower
that's duress do you like the dress
because you because whatever mobile
device you're on could short out you can
ruin it well that's the point - but you
keep you bring the phone into the shower
cold shower 30 seconds get out make your
pick hot shower 45 seconds can I'll make
your pick hmm
that's direct Eve molted multi-touch
because when the draft comes has 45
seconds yeah you got people talking in
your what are you gonna do away lucky
look you're lucky if it's 45 seconds are
you aware of Chris Brockman's fantasy
team what's your story
oh you're aware my draft takes about
anywhere between 7 to 8 hours
doing what there's no we have no time
limits what kind of these people you'll
have a wife my college friends family
they have lots of there's like 18 kids
our league that's the one weekend away
so we all sit in the cells you imagine
could you imagine it took one guy 28
minutes 1 year to draft Brian Hartline
in the 8th George I would in the 8th
round I would have killed somebody you
call these people publicly your friends
my friends are idiot I do they're idiots
but they're my friends I don't want
anything to do with that Ravalli would
you would you go would you go to a spot
where you're drafting hamburgers where
you where you where you order burgers
that you want and then they're all
placed in the middle of the table and
then there's a actual order that you
would be able to draft the burgers that
are left on the table we do a fantasy
burger travel with a time limit ain't
doing is eight hours ooh the burger trap
would you want to come next year I need
to run that up the flagpole man hi hi
honey - I live 20 July 23rd you already
have a date for next season my birthday
yeah I I I'm not going to commit on live
TV and radio to that deck III can't
commit on that because I'm a man of my
word is that's not I'm not saying I got
to run that up the flag on the maybe in
the 15 seconds we have left you want to
look in the Cameron
backtalk Jerry Cantrell who's coming up
I think he won the league last year did
fluke fluke I'm gonna put you in some
chains the whole group
Allison chain this sheer fantasy there
Gary Michael Rapaport everybody so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint